no matter who your preferred and that it is
in the 2020 democratic primary, we cannot
deny at this point the reality of a Bernie
Sanders surge
in the last three weeks and the corresponding
establishment panic that is coming with it
equally.
Can't be denied.
I've got receipts for you coming up, but let's
look at the whole picture.
Starting with the national polls and the national
polls.
Bernie Sanders represented by the light blue
line on your screen indicated by the red arrow
has been surging for weeks and Bernie is now
fewer than five points behind Joe Biden in
an average of recent polls.
Meanwhile, Elizabeth Warren has fallen off.
Joe Biden is mostly even over the last period
of time.
No one else is doing much other than Pete.
Boot.
Edge edge is down slightly.
Mike Bloomberg has been gaining, as I told
you previously.
Let's now look at Iowa.
Iowa is the first state to vote voting on
Monday, the Iowa caucuses, February 3rd Bernie
Sanders climbing there from barely third place
to a 3.2 percentage point.
Lead over Joe Biden into first place in an
average of recent Iowa polling.
Second state to vote is New Hampshire where
Bernie Sanders was also in fourth place some
months ago, but has now taken a sizable lead
24 to 16 over Joe Biden, Biden just imploding
and you Hampshire, while Elizabeth Warren
just can't seem to get any of her momentum
from a few months ago back now admittedly
the third and fourth States to vote in the
primary, which are Nevada and South Carolina.
Not going Bernie's way, but then we get to
March 3rd super Tuesday where there are two
big prizes, both of which are looking quite
solid for Bernie Sanders.
First you've got California where Bernie is
now just slightly in the lead and an average
of recent polls, 24.3 to 23 ahead of Joe Biden
and then this is very interesting in Texas,
Bernie certainly not winning in an average
of recent polls in Texas, but a very strong
showing and the latest poll, a Texas Lyceum
poll where it is a statistical tie for first
is a poll out of Texas that has Biden 28 Bernie
26 that is a statistical tie because of the
margin of error.
Now, what is the establishment doing?
They're panicking.
The establishment has not yet put together
a coherent United plan to stop Bernie.
There's discussion of could the a nomination
be denied to Bernie at the DNC?
That might be too brazen.
We're seeing publications like the New York
times run negative articles about so-called
Bernie bros and article criticizing Bernie's
online supporters.
David Frum wrote an article in the Atlantic
claiming that Bernie Sanders simply can't
win.
There's a New York magazine piece by Jonathan
Chait saying that a Bernie nomination would
be quote, an act of insanity.
I have no idea what's going to happen.
I don't know if Bernie Sanders will be the
nominee.
I believe Elizabeth Warren is done.
Okay.
When I look at the numbers, I see the following.
Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders are going to
battle this out.
They are both going to pull delegates from
early States.
Remember, as long as you get at least 15%
of the vote in these primaries, you get a
corresponding percentage of the delegates.
If you're under 15% you get zero.
So increasingly what we're going to see is
a lot of people get zero.
You're going to see a lot of zeros for Amy
Klobuchar and Andrew Yang and tool C and P
budaj edge is even going to have some zeros.
Elizabeth Warren peaked almost time Joe Biden
months ago, and it's been a decline since
then.
So I believe at this point that it is Biden
versus Bernie with the outside possibility
of Michael Bloomberg becoming a contender.
Now, why do I say that Bloomberg is, um, uh,
only in, in fourth place right now?
Well, if you look at polling change over the
last two months, Michael Bloomberg started
with nothing and he just bought his way in.
Let's not pretend that he did it based on
the issues Bloomberg poured money in and he
surpassed, you know, Castro and Klobuchar
and tool C and yang.
And he even now is taking over, uh, Pete budaj
edge, uh, for fourth place.
So I believe that if anyone has a momentum
trajectory, if he keeps pouring money in,
it is possibly Michael Bloomberg.
If you look at the uh, the, uh, bedding, you
can look at how people are betting on the
democratic primary.
You will see that the betting is a Bernie
followed by Biden followed by um, uh, followed
by Michael Bloomberg.
So what we do know is the establishment is
panicking about Bernie.
I'm curious in the way that people get curious
about a car crash or something horrible.
Like I'm curious and scared about what they're
going to try over the next few weeks.
And my question to you today is what do you
believe, well, two part question.
Do you believe a coherent single strategy
will develop from the democratic establishment
to deny Bernie Sanders the nomination?
And if you do, what will its components be?
Okay, let me know.
On Twitter, I'm on Twitter at D Pacman